he had to know there was some guarantee
in boxing I alluded to it I knew there
was conversation of him versus Fury so
the chance of that happened are highly
likely that's why he's able to
confidently walk away from the UFC so
you saw Fury come out with that video he
wants to do him first Francis and MMA
gloves and Mike Tyson's the Wrath yep
Mike Tyson's probably not going to be
around right even that MMA gloves I
don't need I'd rather just be in boxing
it should be boxing so you can be
barefooted Fury but it just shows you
Furious that's why you love him he's a
Madman he's a gypsy he just wants to
fight but for Francis he made the right
choice because he knows that Fury fights
actually come a few at fruition that's
why things going on